[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau à 7,8
sport le magazine y consacrer comme vous
le savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire
rugby le sky débuté sa saison contre
menti mais ce dimanche à domicile pour
cette reprise le match s'est soldé par
une victoire sur le fil des saint
quentinois sur le score de 23 à 22 les
détails dans ce magazine cyclisme sur
piste jeannette augusto 82 ans réussit a
établi un record de l'heure ou d'enfants
sa catégorie d'âge au vélotour national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines pas sportif
porté pour l'occasion le maillot de
leusse et vélizy 78 qui vous entendez
cette mamie record dans cette émission
golf le parisse legends championship le
rendez vous sportif pour les anciennes
légendes de la discipline est organisé
en trois jours sur les greens du golf
national les spectateurs notamment pu
voir à l'oeuvre le fantasque américain à
john délicieux et puis nous parlerons
également de la ryder cup 2018 la coupe
du monde du golf qui sera organisée dans
un peu moins d'un an à 50 ans livin on
commence tout de suite
ce magazine par l'actualité sportive de
la semaine
[Musique]
du rugby pour débuter ce magazine en
championnat ile de france honneur le sky
rugby ce n'a pas manqué son retour après
trois ans d'absence les saint quentinois
sont venus à bout de manque lit mais sur
leur terrain le score 23 à 22
un résultat acquis dans les dernières
secondes dans une ambiance électrique le
résumé du match par nicolas landry
[Applaudissements]
c'est la pénalité de la gagne pour le
sky rugby un succès sur le fil 23 à 22
face à longtemps tu mentes lit mais une
victoire importante pour les saint
quentinois promu en division honneur
cette saison
ça fait du bien de revenir avec une
victoire et c'est vrai que moi à
l'époque j'étais j'étais pas au sky
le capitaine y était et son mode fin de
match c'est à dire que vous avez failli
deux saisons sans aucune victoire en
honneur et de recommencer à landivisiau
heures par une victoire ça fait du bien
à tout le monde au moral
pourtant rien n'a été simple dans cette
partie des conditions climatiques
compliquées pas de grandes envolées un
ballon glissant les fautes de mains se
multiplient avec la discipline des deux
équipes la première période s'est
résumée à un duel de buteurs
à la mi-temps manque limay mène 12 à 6
on a commencé le vent dans le nez pour
un peu plus de fraîcheur premières
minutes on les en première mi-temps
voulait tenir le ballon et essayer de
relancer à la main ont séduit en
deuxième mi temps on aura le vent dans
le dos on pourra sortir de chez nous un
peu plus au pied au retour des
vestiaires les nantais sont réduits à 14
ils encaissent directement un premier
essai
[Musique]
et suite à une touche à l'entrée des 22
mètres le bus de skype envers ses
joueurs montés pour doubler la mise
[Applaudissements]
à dix minutes de la fin les hommes de
thomas payen men 20 à 12
mais les mantais réagissent et puis y
mettre une pénalité un quart d'heure de
la fin et reviennent à cinq points et
dans les cinq dernières minutes une
touche il avance on fait une faute une
deuxième touché ils finissent dans
l'angle qui termine devant trois minutes
de la fin on est un peu en un peu sous
pression pour les dernières minutes la
pression les saint quentinois l'ong
gérés pour finalement l'emporter
une expérience acquise pour le
déplacement de dimanche prochain à cergy
pontoise pour le compte de la deuxième
journée de la division honneur
on va continuer à parler de rugby on va
descendre d'une division pour rejoindre
le championnat de promotion d'honneur
monti le bretonneux et promis cette
saison dans cette division le club a
effectué sa rentrée à domicile contre
marcoussis ce dimanche lésigny montants
ont été défaits à l'extérieur contre
cette équipe sur le score de 27 à 3 pour
nous parler de ce premier match des
ambitions du club cette saison nous
recevons sur ce plateau
l'entraîneur des avants assez les
mûriers le capitaine de l'équipe
williams pautrat bonsoir alors cyril on
va rapidement revenir sur ce ce premier
match de la saison qu'est ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné
le disait 27 à 3 découverte d'une
nouvelle division une équipe plus
puissante équipe qu'on rencontrait
années précédentes donc une buts en
première mi temps très difficile
puisqu'ils ont été menés 20 à 3 mi-temps
à nous de trouver les solutions pour
pour compenser ce déficit est
il va mettre davantage de vitesse de
créer de l'avancé enfin deux de
retrouver la victoire rapide du coup
williams si je comprends bien en
deuxième mi temps ça allait mieux mais
comme le disait cyril en première mi
temps on a peut-être eu du mal à mettre
en place notre jeu à trouver nos repères
dans une vision qu'on connaissait pour
la plupart pas comme on est tous novices
à ce niveau là et au bout de 40 minutes
on a réussi à mettre petit à petit notre
jeu en place même s'il y avait encore
beaucoup de difficultés mais on a pris
des repères on s'est un peu plus se
retrouver sur le terrain et on va dire
que c'est une mi-temps qui est de bonne
augure qui est avec des signes
d'encouragement on va dire pour pour la
suite avec des bases de travail assez
sympa qu'est-ce qu'il faudra améliorer
coach si elle mûriers pour les prochains
matches aller du travail la conquête la
précision
je pense que williams que les
entraînements vont être difficiles en
concierge doit on s'y attendait un petit
peu oui
du coup vous pouvez continuer non ben
juste voilà maintenant arrive à mettre
davantage de vitesse dans notre jeu est
plus précis et toute la précision et
mais le groupe a bien répondu
globalement à 23 mi temps ça aurait pu
se poser ils ont été vaillants et
courageux qui doit aussi une après midi
difficile et
serrer les coudes tout là tout le match
et on est là avant tout pour ça nous ce
qu'on demande aux joueurs c'est des gens
positifs et on fera avec les en positif
et on va y arriver
william vous pensez que l'apprentissage
va être compliqué cette saison vous
sentez qui est un cran de plus par
rapport à l'avant qui a un cran
peut-être au niveau de la vitesse
d'exécution la nuit au niveau du jeu de
aussi des impacts physiques on est
toujours en a toujours eu un petit
déficit même la dernière en division
inférieure on sent que ça va être
difficile sur ça mais au vu de la vidéo
j'ai aperçu c'est un petit peu
aujourd'hui la vidéo du match on sent
qu'on a les capacités
quand on voit le match même dans le jeu
en deuxième mi temps comme on se disait
on sentait qu'on avait on aurait pu
avoir les clés mais qu'il faut
travailler un petit peu plus pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir acquérir tous à
aimer mais ouais on est optimiste et
surtout on va pas les quarts pas le
réduire
ouais ouais absolument sinon ça serait
dommage de se dire des premiers matchs
que c'est pas possible mais on est con
fiance avec ça va être compliqué mais on
est confiant on va tout faire pour cirer
muret l'année dernière vous étiez
quasiment invaincu vous gagnez tout vous
avez gagné tous vos matchs cette saison
ça être beaucoup plus compliqué comment
on prépare à ses joueurs mentalement à
une saison plus difficile que les
saisons précédentes
ces nouvelles problématiques le fait
d'avoir été ainsi qu'une saison est
d'avoir une équité de france pour la
confiance et pour le passé de l'équipe
c'est important voilà le ce qui est plus
intéressant c'est de se confronter à
plus fort que soi et d'être le poil à
gratter de la poule cette saison a pas
pas de secret je pense que les joueurs
environ vont s'accrocher
certains étaient très déçus donc ça
c'est bon signe il n'y a pas de remède
miracle
williams il faudra apprendre à perdre
cette saison
j'aime pas trop dire ça mais oui il va
falloir apprendre à perdre ça a été je
veux dire la première leçon hier on a
vécu l'année dernière comme vous disiez
invaincu toute la saison et c'est
peut-être un mal pour un bien de
commencer par une défaite à l'extérieur
chez un cador de la poule on va dire ça
comme ça pour pour dire que vraiment nié
en ph
en promotion honneur par loin que et qui
va falloir y aller
être courageux dans le vestiaire c'était
comment la fin du match compliqué ouais
il ya eu cinq dix minutes où personne
n'a trop parler où on avait tous un peu
la tête baissée le regard dans le vide
et puis après comme je dis aux garçons
on est là pour le plaisir on n'est pas
des rugbymen professionnels c'est si on
est là pour se retrouver sa muse et donc
ça a été un peu mieux après mais on est
des compétiteurs quoi qu'il arrive des
rugbymans et on aime la victoire donc
forcément ça pas été très rigolo début
serré mûriers il faut viser quoi
concrètement cette saison les deux
objectifs
on prend aussi honneur on obligé d'avoir
une équipe réserve à 15 toute l'année
contrairement à la première série donc
créé une équipe réserve et le deuxième
au niveau de la première on va être le
poil à gratter on veut être l'équipe qui
va embêter tout le monde est ici cinq
opus confie bien si on arrive à être au
coeur du championnat à noël on travaille
en bien sûr janvier-février et peut-être
une petite troisième place
les chercher on ne sait jamais vous
pensez avoir l'effectif pour atteindre
ces objectifs si on n'a pas trop de
blessures oui on a le monde qu'il faut
malheureusement déjà perdu notre demeure
80 yens moreau hier n'être absent au
moins 3,3 bonbons mais si les gars on se
donne les moyens
ils vont y arriver aucun doute là dessus
williams le premier bilan il se fera à
quel moment premières afin d de la phase
aller peut-être ouais comme le disait
cyril on va voir au mois de décembre
à la pause hivernale comment ça va se
passer et c'est à partir de là qu'on va
se ficher fixé pardon je pense la
deuxième
la deuxième partie de saison nos
objectifs sur deuxième partie de saison
et on verra mais mais toujours regarder
vers le haut pas vers le bas toujours
vers le haut toujours voir son niveau
d'exigence à la hausse et il y aura pas
de raison c'est à la mairie est ce que
vous avez fait une préparation optimum
pour aller préparer pour cette nouvelle
saison préparations de rugby dit le chic
pas plus que l'année dernière non merci
au moins on a essayé j'ai des garçons se
décompresser ce que l'année dernière on
avait des objectifs élevés et ce ne sont
que des amateurs qu'ils soient étudiants
ceux qui bossent donc il y en a fait un
break et ils sont revenus avec plein
d'invités l'envi qui fait avancer le
groupe a une marge de progression
une très grosse marge de progression
d'autant qu'on est la dernière en
finisse et un cycle de trois ans là on
repart à nouveau 6 et un jour nous ont
quittés et d'autres viennent on a
quelques juniors qui montent donc ya pas
de raison williams pour faire pencher la
balance de votre côté dans les matches à
domicile est ce que vous avez besoin du
soutien vos supporters ils viennent
souvent le week-end pour me soutenir ce
qu'il en faut encore plus à vous
dépasser
j'appelle tous les inimitiés nîmes
antenne à venir nous voir et nous
supporter évidemment plus on a du monde
un domicile plus on sent le soutien
derrière nous plus ça nous donne de ça
ça nous permet de nous de nous dépasser
et de mouiller le maillot comme on dit
et de et d'aller chercher la victoire
encore plus
mais oui c'est sûr c'est sur la location
cl mûriers un pronostic sur le match
ce dimanche ça sera contre garches à
domicile gary domicile guérit les 100
donneurs ben si on a un point de plus
que la fois du match on sera satisfait
même pronostic voyage tranquille à peu
près tout dit une victoire
moi j'aimerais bien et on fait rien ou
en tout cas merci à tous le deuil est
passé sur ce plat tout merci vous avoir
parlé du club de montigny-le-bretonneux
on vous souhaite de réaliser une
magnifique saison et de faire rêver le
public
iny montrent un merci à tous les deux
sinon si on continue à parler de rugby
avec le club de versailles dans le
championnat ile de france honneur les
versailles est favori pour la montée ont
réalisé un bon début de championnat en
venant à bout de leurs voisins
gif-sur-yvette à l'extérieur lors de la
première journée le score 23 à 300 le
bonus offensif
un résultat qui permet aux joueurs de la
cité royale d'occuper le haut du
classement du championnat
de son côté la réserve s'est imposée 60
à 0 toujours sur le terrain de gif sur
yvette
prochain match dimanche prochain à 15
heures à porsche fontaine contre
goussainville en fédérale 2 le promu
plaisir n'y arrive toujours pas les
plaisirs oies ont été défaits sur leur
terrain contre beauvais sur le score de
53 à 29 leur troisième défaite en trois
matches disputés cette saison dans ce
championnat
en classement plaisir est avant dernier
avec zéro point et une différence de
moins 90 contre au moins 96 pour la
lanterne rouge d'hautmont en football on
jouer sur les terrains de régionale 4
trappe se dépasser ce dimanche à lognes
pour le compte de la 4e journée du
championnat et rap s'est incliné lors de
cette rencontre sur le score de 1-0 au
niveau du classement trappe sur le
podium avant la rencontre des sens et
pointent désormais à la 5e place du
championnat avec un bilan de deux
victoires et deux défaites
on continue ce magazine par un record
jeannette augusto à 82 ans vient
d'établir une performance exceptionnelle
dans la catégorie d'âge 80 ans et plus
elle a réalisé 28 2 126 km en 1h sur la
piste du verdon national de saint
quentin en yvelines
une première mondiale la sportive qui
portait le maillot de lens et vélizy 78
s'est même offert le luxe de réaliser
112 tours de piste quatre de plus que
les prévisions de ses coachs on écoute
les réactions au micro de tv 78 et ça
s'est très bien passé
et je ne pensais vraiment pas faire une
telle performance
alors là franchement non non non je
voulais pas descendre en dessous les
vingt-sept et bien là je crois que je
suis gâté il ya toujours une part
d'incertitude
on n'est jamais sûr d'aller jusqu'au
bout et jeannette elle ne s'est jamais
désuni elle a toujours rouler
régulièrement
et puis elle n'a jamais fléchi surtout
jusqu'à la fin elle a été régulière et
ça c'est une une très très grande leçon
même tout pour tous les grands cyclistes
à la fin de son record jeannette a
annoncé vouloir arrêter officiellement
la compétition sur cette performance on
lui tire une nouvelle fois un grand coup
de chapeau à eux aussi à pourrait battre
les records de longévité mais dans leur
discipline de prédilection le golfe la
deuxième édition du paris cela jones
championship et est organisé pendant
trois jours sur les greens du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
une cinquantaine de légende est venu
pour se disputer ce trophée du seigneur
tour parmi eux le fantasque américain
john delli les images sont signés à
nicolas landry 54 légendes du golf à
saint quentin en yvelines bienvenue aux
parisse les djeuns championship la
compétition était organisée pour la
seconde fois sur le parcours de
l'albatros avec un plateau d'exception
c'est une épreuve de deluz open senior
tour c'est la douzième épreuve je crois
de du calendrier de ce circuit
professionnel
c'est l'open de france seniors et puis
après on a des pointures mondiales comme
john delli comme paul broadhurst comme
costantino rocca voilà des joueurs qui
nous ont fait vibrer il ya quelques
années qui joue encore très très bien au
total plus de 4500 spectateurs se sont
rendus sur les greens du golf national
pour admirer ces champions c'est un très
joli tournoi avec des gens qu'on a
connus dali fin des grandes et grands
joueurs et masi colvert enfin j'ai bien
aimé jusqu'à maintenant j'ai bien aimé
ça intéresse un public notamment
beaucoup de gens qui ont passé la
soixantaine joue encore au golf donc on
est toujours à pas concerner qu'un des
gens de notre âge qui joue encore et qui
joue aussi bien après trois jours de
compétition c'est finalement l'anglais
paul broadhurst qui remporte la
compétition 22 ans après avoir remporté
l'open de france à saint quentin en
yvelines avec un total de -12 il devance
la star américaine jeunes délit de deux
coups
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
troisième édition le pari sly johnson
championship a débuté le jeudi à 28
septembre
un an pile du premier match de la ryder
cup 2018 la coupe du monde du golf
troisième événement le plus regardé au
monde qui se tiendra sur le parcours de
l'albatros du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
nous sommes allés prendre la température
à un an de cette compétition qui devrait
attirer près de 60000 personnes par jour
nous sommes au golf national à mes côtés
paul hermitage et nous sommes à un an
tout juste de la ryder cup qui va se
dérouler ici sur le parcours de
l'albatros paul hermitage
est ce qu'à un an de l'épreuve tout est
prêt alors non tout n'est pas prêt mais
on est bien dans notre planning
c'est à dire ben c'est à dire que toutes
les préparations du parcours ne sont pas
actuellement terminé mais on a fait 95 %
la dernière pièce affaire est en train
d'être fait sur le parcours de l'aigle
assez paradoxalement et puis après sur
le site nous nos travaux sont faits
après il faut qu'on suit le plan
d'entretien sur le parcours correctement
pour espérer dans un an très exactement
avoir un parcours aussi beau aussi c'est
pas plus beau encore aujourd'hui oui
justement vous avez fait des travaux du
coup l'année dernière est ce que le
parcours est différent
oui le parcours a changé parce que pour
deux raisons premièrement parce que en
art n avait pas mal d'éléments on a
changé quelques
parti au niveau de l' architecture et
puis aussi en a préparé pour tous les
spectateurs et toutes les personnes qui
vont être sur le site pendant
l'événement plus de 60000 65000 et
et pour ça on a dû enlever pas mal de
végétation et en termes du coût
d'infrastructure est ce que le parcours
est plus dure qu'avant ou plus facile
alors non moi je pense qu'il n'est pas
plus dur qu'avant
sincèrement je pense qu'il a changé
parce que le programme qui a été mis en
place depuis cinq ans maintenant
consister à mieux drainer de parcours
donc on a apporté énormément de sable
presque une quinzaine de centimètres sur
les far away pour mieux drainer et donc
le sable ça rend les fermer un peu plus
plus dur quelque part mais moins roulant
c'est aussi quelque chose donc il est un
peu plus lent et les greens je les
trouve très rapide mais il sent plus
juste il était un peu trop dur avant
tandis qu'ils sont un peu plus soft
aujourd'hui au niveau de l'accueil du
public est ce qu'il reste des choses à
faire
est ce qu'il reste des infrastructures
et à construire au niveau du public
alors oui il ya toutes les
infrastructures éphémère construire donc
pour cela il ya un plan qui est déjà
dessinée et on va commencer ces
constructions ou ryder cup europe va
commencer ces constructions autour du 15
avril 2018 pour se terminer
fin septembre après pour l'événément
donc il ya pu y rester six mois de
travaux il y aura quelques éléments qui
vont apparaître avant l'open de france
l'année prochaine
c'est pas pour cela ça tombe bien parce
que c'est le même promoteur sur les
mêmes organisateurs donc ça ne va pas
croisé où on peut pas se marcher dessus
avec un autre opérateur comme cette
semaine pour réparer la jones par
exemple qui n'est pas le même opérateur
que que le à chennai open de france de
la ryder cup donc les constructions
éphémères n'ont pas encore commencé
le tout les plans sont destinés tout le
le terrain est préparé c'est à dire en à
l'eau potable aux efforts électricité la
wii fornas le fibre optique là où il
faut et on à stabiliser les sols là où
il faut également pour accueillir des
structures de deux étages donc mi
octobre il y aura les deux capitaines
ryder cup qui font une conférence de
presse ainsi que ils vont péter de la
tour eiffel est-ce que ça y est c'est
enfin là la pression monte
est-ce que vous ressentez vous ici au
golf national oui on sent depuis
peut-être deux trois mois maintenant une
vraie vraie émulation
les billets pour les billets garantis
pour la le public français c'était
avant-hier la mise en vente
tout est parti en 50 minutes c'est mieux
qu'un concert de madonna ou aussi bien
que céline dion en tout cas donc on est
très très content ça ventre qui en ont
un
l'engouement peut-être qu'on n'a pas
ressenti jusqu alors donc maintenant
effectivement vous avez raison ou annie
et hugo un événement majeur du 16 au 18
octobre d'ailleurs le lundi les
capitaines vont jouer 4 ou le 15 16 17
18 jeux sur le golf national sur le golf
national avec des jeunes et c'est ouvert
au public on va vous donner plus de
précisions et quand les uns dont vous
pouvez venir regardez et admirez ses
deux capitaines gratuitement et puis
trois jours d'événements qui marque oui
le coup d'envoi la dernière ligne droite
avant 2018
ça y est la pression monte alors la
pression je pense qu'on l'a déjà depuis
depuis un bon moment
je pense qu'elle a été à son auteur ou
le plus haut niveau le plus élevé quand
il fallait sortir les travaux et être
solidaire avec alejandro et ses équipes
sur le terrain maintenant du côté du
golf national la pression elle est là
parce que on s'inquiète du bon déroulé
mais et on reste très humble
avec beaucoup d'humilité devant les
tâches à venir mais maintenant que ces
travaux sont derrière nous du côté du
golf national on est un peu plus serein
sur le plan sportif
est ce qu'il y aura des français pour
cette ryder cup 2018 alors je pense
qu'il ya tous les espoirs possible
d'avoir un français dans l'équipe ray
parce qu'il se donne les moyens
ils bossent dur
on les voit
en plus ils sont très très motivés c'est
dans leur pays c'est la première fois
pour une certaine génération je pense
que c'est peut-être aussi la seule fois
même si ça peut revenir un peu plus tard
ça reviendra pas pendant quelques années
tant que c'est une chance inouïe de
vraiment briller devant son public et
dans son pays
cc france 2018 c'est la ryder cup 2018
donc ils font un français dans donc la
ryder cup 2018 si dans moins d'un an
ici aussi le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines le golf et la ryder
cup s'exporte également dans les classes
depuis la rentrée trente mille élèves de
cm1-cm2 apprennent le recours de manière
ludique à travers un livre est baptisé à
mon carnet de golf au programme des
mathématiques de l'anglais de la
géographie et du français à
voisins-le-bretonneux une classe a
adopté ce dispositif créé par la
fédération française saint quentin en
yvelines et l'éducation nationale à
montage de jules haag relèvent ils
cet après midi dans cette classe de
wazemmes bretonne une session
particulière les élèves et leurs
professeurs utilisent mon carnet de golf
un programme éducatif créé dans le cadre
de la ryder cup 2018 la coupe du monde
de la discipline qui s'organisait à
saint quentin en yvelines
objectif apprendre de façon ludique les
matières scolaires
on a deux thèmes généraux départ
découvrir le golf et découvrir la ryder
cup
donc je découvre je progresse
j'approche et je retiens
lorsque les enfants ont parcouru donc
ces pages ils ont déjà une culture assez
étendue par rapport au thème c'est c'est
vraiment bénéfique
après avoir testé la première version du
carnet de golf en 2015 la professeur n'a
pas hésité à renouveler l'expérience
pour cette nouvelle année scolaire afin
de stimuler les élèves
c'est évident que d'avoir en fil rouge
un projet dans la classe qui plusieurs
projets sportifs parce que les enfants
aiment beaucoup le sport beaucoup
d'activités sportives
ça permet vraiment de calais d
apprentissage sans que la difficulté ou
tout ce qui est trop abstrait où tout ce
qui est trop technique ne prenne le
dessus des apprentissages qui se font
tout seuls sans que les élèves ne soient
bloqués par l'aspect trop théorique en
phase d apprentissage
une recette qui fonctionne les 26 élèves
de cette classe plébiscitent ce
programme d'enseignement créée par la
fédération française 50 henri vinay
l'éducation nationale
[Musique]
un peu de mal et ça nous apprend les
règles du golf à ce qui me plaît c'est
que on travaille en même temps un jour
parce que c'est marrant on va dire ça va
prendre plusieurs choses à la fois donc
c'est marrant même temps et comment fait
il ya plusieurs matières mais du coup
pas cela l'après midi s'est terminé par
une cession de golf l'occasion de mettre
en pratique leurs acquis de s'entraîner
en vue de fouler le green de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une sortie
scolaire est programmée d'ici la fin de
l'année
un mode horde balle à présent triste
nouvelle pour le sport et vinuales il y
monte un flip médard en verre sur la
photo médaillé olympique à barcelone en
1992 avec les fameux barjots c'était 1
ce samedi à 58 ans des suites d'une
longue maladie
depuis le début des années 2000 le
gardien aider le club de l'ès montillot
bretenoux il avait également exercé des
fonctions dans l'administration
communale à la direction des services
techniques et à la direction des sports
on passe maintenant notre rubrique
agenda
[Musique]
on commence donc cet agenda par de la
boxe l'élan courtois marvin petit 26 ans
va remonter sur le ring le 10 novembre
prochain paris boxeur de la team
farruggia va affronter samir kasmi 34
ans trois fois champion de france son
objectif lors de son combat défende son
titre de l'union européenne à qui cette
année malgré un meilleur bilan que son
adversaire 21 victoires pour une seule
défaite contre 22 victoires et 13
défaites pour samir kasmi élan courtois
ne veux pas avoir le statut de favori on
les écoute personne est favori d'un
combat mais on va dire on va rester
prudent on va boucher comme quand comme
il faut en mettre une stratégie en place
et on verra bien à la fin mais bon pour
moi pour moi je pense gagner parce que
je mens pas sur mon permis à notre
rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas la
ville de plaisir organise son troisième
run and bike le samedi 7 octobre le
concept un duo doit enchaîner le vélo et
la course à pied pendant la compétition
au programme cinq parcours de deux à
quinze kilomètres dans le domaine du
château est là et de la boi de la crâne
si vous êtes intéressé l'événement est
programmée à partir de 9h30 les
organisateurs attendent plus de quatre
cent soixante concurrents pour cette
édition 2010 est celle afin de 7,8 sport
merci l'avoir su on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro je vous
laisse avec des images du mini concert
organisé au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant le
parisse les djeuns championship
l'américain john delli vainqueur de deux
grands chelems dans les années 90 ses
deuxièmes de la compétition c'est aussi
pousser la chansonnette
à bientôt sur tb 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sita
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]